ya hace unos años que era como un súper
término pero con esto en el manga aún
avanzando y con el éxito que tuvo es más
que seguro que tendremos más dragon ball
super pero a pesar de que así es muy
buena es innegable que tuvo unos errores
horribles en ciertas partes que más o
menos han tratado de corregir con el
tiempo o no otros mal animación
personajes ridículos los niveles de
poder mandados a la puc
y la falta de sangre y contenido más
adulto la serie de fallas muchas de las
cosas que hizo ahora comportan grande y
se siente como que super le falta algo
de sabor así que hoy voy a hacer un
recuento de lo que para mí son las cosas
más importantes que la serie debe
mejorar antes de que su historia
continúe cabe decir que no no odio la
serie de meis gusta de hecho me gusta
bastante super y sobre todo su último
arco me encantó pero forma que me gusta
la serie que cualquiera puede notar las
fallas que tiene y tuvo que viste esta
animación y el final cutre la saga de
blanco q sabes de lo que hablo además
una última cosa no voy a mencionar la
animación en este vídeo es claro que la
animación en sus primeros capítulos
seamos honestos está era una [ __ ] y
aunque sigue la de mejorar en el arco el
torneo universal vimos una mejoría
enorme en la animación con los capítulos
con esta mente sea bien
además con la excelente animación de la
última película que ojalá sea esta la
animación con la que se continúe super
ya esto es un problema del que estoy
seguro todos estamos enterados es un
tema que ya todos sabemos que se debe
mejorar así que prefiero profundizar en
otros temas un poco más argumentales del
guión o de transferencia personal
[Música]
seguramente este es uno de los temas más
obvios así que no voy a ahondar mucho en
el dragon ball super tuvo un comienzo
muy flojo porque en vez de comenzar con
la historia original adaptando el manga
lo único que hicieron por decenas de
capítulos fue mostraron lo mismo que ya
habíamos visto en sus dos películas son
los que con más relleno y peor animación
[Música]
yo entiendo que era una película de hora
y media no se tiene tiempo que los
guionistas quisieran para explicar
muchas cosas así que tal vez tal vez su
intención con estas dos sagas iniciales
fue profundizar en ciertos temas que las
películas dejaron algo inconclusos pero
no no hicieron nada de esto que de hecho
ahora sigo bastante interesante si no lo
sacas de la batalla de los dioses y la
resurrección de freezer no le aportan
absolutamente nada a la historia contada
en sus películas incluso creo que las
películas son mil veces mejores que
estas sagas y créeme te ahorras mucho
tiempo hasta llegar a la primera saga
decente y digo esto ya que la película
ebro live fue estrenada después del
final de súper y sería una idea
realmente estúpida comenzar la nueva
serie con su primer arco sido un
reciclaje de la historia de ebro lee la
película es muy buena tiene excelentes
batallas y gran animación tienen la y
comience la nueva temporada directo en
las sagas del prisionero galáctico y les
irá mil veces mejor
[Música]
dragonball super nos ha dado muchos
personajes nuevos en cada arco pero
[ __ ] la mayoría son horribles un
unicum amadísimo un robot que se ofende
por todo y otros con diseños scooters
nuevos con cara de violadores y pájaros
y recuesta este maldito teletubi más
gordo insoportable qué clase de
personajes son estos los personajes de
dragon ball sub tener son malos muy
malos y algunos medianamente buenos como
hit ir en el racing kan o sea más pero
es que el resto son muy malos todos
estos personajes son importantes como
por tres episodios y ya solo sirven para
la trama cuando son presentados en su
propio barco o en momentos muy puntuales
pero más allá de eso no son para más
importantes para la trama no tienen
ningún peso nasser y casi todos
absolutamente irrelevantes son
personajes aburridos vacíos y
transparentes o algunos simplemente
ridículos cuando los ves te cuesta
empatizar con ellos porque son
personajes que sólo están ahí parqué con
jugo vegetales ver una paliza y ya hay
personajes muy buenos y entrañables por
las cuentas con las manos con muy pocos
la serie tiene suficiente material como
para crearlos y de hecho debería crear
personajes realmente interesantes bien
argumentados y con suficiente peso en la
historia no sólo personajes visualmente
incómodos
vínculos en relevancia y sin nada de
argumento
[Música]
cinco barcos es lo que la serie lleva
hasta el momento y el hecho de que de
esos cinco barcos dos sean
recapitulaciones de películas y dos sean
torneos ya nos dice que algo debe
cambiar con súper no digo creíble a los
torneos en la serie sea mala de hecho la
mayoría son muy buenos pero la serie no
puede basarse únicamente en la idea de
los torneos los torneos son geniales
pero en exceso y siendo algunos algo
aburridos pues ya cansa dragón por súper
necesita arcos o sagas mejor
argumentadas menos repetitivas y
predecibles yo entiendo que dragon ball
súper nunca ha sido una serie con
argumento muy complejo yo sé que no pudo
esperar algo a nivel de la joya de edn
out pero se necesitan arcos con algo más
de historia
por ejemplo la saga los androides en
dragon ball será el arco comienza
control del futuro que en ese momento
era un misterio para todos quien podría
ser luego nos enteramos de que frizer
está vivo y se dirige a la tierra tras
acabar con él y nos enteramos de que él
es el hijo de vegueta digo otra línea
temporal se revela lo de la enfermedad
en el corazón de goku y de la existencia
de androides a los que los guerreros
zetas tendrán que enfrentar en el futuro
luego nos enteramos de la existencia de
aún más androides y deseo
en cambio por ejemplo la saga del torneo
el universo 67 comienza porque dos
dioses de la destrucción deidades con
cientos de años de edad se pelean por
comida hacen un torneo para competir por
la mejor comida y ya como dije dragon
ball los que sean a series super
compleja pero sí ha tenido sagas con una
historia fluida pequeños secretos e
historias lo suficientemente
interesantes como para mantenernos al
pendiente pero la mayoría de los arcos
que lasi no nos ha dejado son muy flojos
argumentalmente aunque no todos claro la
saga de blanco q sin contar su
decepcionante final fue muy buena tenía
ese misterio e intriga que sea cada
capítulo interesante de ver y eso es lo
que las tienen necesita arcos nuevos en
donde no sólo se basa en un conflicto a
las arquetas soluciones con un power of
yo sé que la preciada compuesta
mayormente en sus peleas además no es
como digo que necesita una razón muy
complicada para romperse la cara con
quien sea pero sería bueno que además de
batallas grandiosas tengamos una
historia y la altura
[Música]
si los finales el final del arco el
torneo universal fue una maravilla para
mostrarle toda la pelea final con su
música y todo y no emocionante pero
también al final es insatisfactorios por
no decir que son malísimos y el más
claro ejemplo de esto es la saga de
blanco q esta saga yo absolutamente bien
era hasta ese momento la mejor saga de
la serie o por lo menos lo era hasta su
final
por más que nos guste la historia algo
como al vado que el regreso de tronos
del futuro todos estamos de acuerdo con
que tuvo final estimó todas las batallas
y esfuerzos y toda la atención
construida hasta ese momento todo para
que coco en boca ya no esté se enoje y
se cargue toda esa línea tiempo ahora al
punto con sámaras u con un deus ex
machina en toda tu [ __ ] cara de nada
sirve que los guionistas tienen una
buena historia es el final de esta
historia nos dejan con un final cutre
insatisfactorio ya que en el puesto
anterior comenté que sería bueno que
crearan mejores historias pues al menos
si se van a esforzar en buenas historias
sólo menos de orientarles un final
decente
[Música]
desde dragon ball hasta dragon ball z
tuvimos a personajes como boku vegueta
picor o bojan y muchos muchos otros que
durante años tuvieron un continuo
desarrollo que concluyó con la saga de
ma jin wook al final de dragon ball z o
q era alguien muy poderoso un genio del
combate pero también responsable serio
cuando debía hacer lo que entendía sus
límites y que siempre quería superarse a
sí mismo y aunque algo infantil en
ocasiones era alguien maduro y con mucho
corazón
vegueta había dejado de lado su orgullo
como príncipe saya jean y admitió que
coco es superior a él y dejó atrás su
odio hacía muchas cosas para ser más
humano wang había retomado su deseo de
luchar desde la saga de ceal
comprometiéndose una vez más hacia el
protector de la tierra y de esta misma
manera muchos otros personajes tuvieron
desarrollo preciso crecer como
personajes pero en súper todo este
desarrollo se fue arcano
o cuén dragon ball super la mayoría de
ocasiones es un perfecto imbécil dejó de
ser un guerrero responsable maduro y
carismático hasta un [ __ ] que abandona
a su familia y es capaz de arriesgar al
universo entero y la vida de todos sus
amigos y familiares por agarrarse a
palos con quien sea vegueta retoma ese
orgullo y odio así el 90% de las cosas
que los rodean y su actitud de kampar
está bastante ausente yo entiendo que el
final será con bolsita dejó las cosas ya
sus personajes listos para un cierre con
una continuación se tenían que hacer
algunos cambios en los mismos personajes
para que la historia récord de sentido y
sus personajes tengan metas y nuevo
desarrollo y crecimiento pero es seguro
que pueden haber hecho mejor trabajo
los personajes necesitan ser escritos y
manejados de una mejor manera a pesar de
que goku en ocasiones si vuelve a ser
goku a enojarse por las cosas que duelen
a usar su inteligencia en las batallas
hacia el cocu de antes y aunque la
mayoría de personajes en ocasiones si se
toman un rumbo muy adecuado su
personalidad hay muchas otras ocasiones
donde se siente como si los personajes
de dragon ball super fueron los mismos
que de dragon ball z sólo queda una
versión más infantil sumándole a ello
que muchos de los personajes que alguna
vez imponían respeto en dragon ball z
ahora son ridiculizados y tratados en
respeto alguno nuevamente y me disculpo
porque voy a repetir a mí mismo pero yo
sé que coco no es un personaje muy
complejo y la mayoría de personajes en
dragon ball tampoco pero siento que lo
que estoy debería hacer es escribir
mejorar sus personajes darles un poco
más de seriedad y profundidad
deben entender mejor a sus propios
personajes y tener el respeto suficiente
como para darles un buen desarrollo
bueno aquí quiero hacer un paréntesis
antes de continuar los demás temas
quiero comentar algunos detalles mínimos
que tal vez no sean tan importantes pero
que siento que deberían ser discutidos
previamente primero su banda sonora
dragon ball z tener una banda sonora
asombrosa escuchen
[Música]
antes
y
[Música]
y ahora comparemos con algunas piezas de
la banda sonora de super
[Música]
qué asco qué patético qué horrible que
es agradable qué vergüenza qué bueno no
siendo honestos dragonball su puerta
tiene sus temazos pero a pesar de esto
la mayoría de su música sobre todo al
principio de la serie se siente
malditamente ridícula infantil
simplemente fea a comparación de lo
bonito que se ve aragón ball z y aunque
sí es cierto que en sus últimos arcos
otra como el super sí que está mejorando
muchísimo que su banda sonora espero que
sigan así y no vuelvan a poner ese tipo
de cosas como ese horrendo tema la banda
de pilas y ya como último detalle así
que me amarga la existencia tenemos y el
doblaje y no no me refiero el doblaje de
voz de los personajes y tampoco me
pienso meter una discusión de cuál
doblar es mejor si el doblaje bien no
ves no a todo gas con una vital de
españa o el dólar es perrones de méxico
obviamente es mucho mejor el de méxico
sino que lo que me refiero es que
deberían dejar de hablar las canciones
de la serie que en serio al rible porque
sé que esto es un problema que está
presente tanto en el doblaje al inglés y
en el doblaje latino no estoy seguro que
en el castellano también por ejemplo en
latinoamérica los links y opening es
absolutamente normal que se graben y se
traduzcan pero en esta ocasión lo
hicieron a una manera terrible los links
y opening de la serie en vez de dejar
los originales que son geniales los
doblaron de una manera terrible y se
oyen horribles en américa si los
tradujeron medianamente bien no son para
nada mal pero otro ejemplo y el más
claro creo yo el tema del ultra instinto
no sé qué mente iluminada fue el que
tuvo la idea de traducir una de las
mejores canciones de la serie y arruinar
la nuestros doblajes en fin estos dos
detalles son como dije detalles mínimos
tampoco son detalles a tomarse muy en
serio como además estos dos temas son
más de opinión personal y entiendo que
cada quien tiene sus gustos y desde
respetarse pero da y los dejo ahora sí
continuemos con los temas principales
es curioso cómo a pesar de que llevamos
cinco arcos entra como el super hemos
tenido un solo verdadero villano
sitúese blanco q o lo que viene siendo
básicamente lo mismo jamás si nos
ponemos a pensar en la saga de los
dioses vistos un villano solo es un dios
cumpliendo con sus deberes de destructor
freezer en la siguiente saga cuenta pero
es un villano de la con bolsita no era
como el súper hit no es un villano
tampoco y el arco del torneo universal
absolutamente nadie es un villano son
personas luchando por sobrevivir perdón
se recurre mucho las comparaciones con
dragon ball z pero son necesarias en z
tuvimos villanos carismáticos y muy bien
construidos personajes icónicos siendo
nuevamente otra cosa de lo que carece la
serie la saga de tronos del futuro fue
muy buena en mayor parte por sus
villanos porque de cierta manera se
siente el riesgo de enfrentarlos sus
motivaciones y algo que los hace
destacar como verdaderas amenazas en los
demás arcos son sólo personas que luchan
contra los guerreros zeta
vegueta o boku y capítulos después
terminan siendo amigotes se echa de
menos la creación de villanos villanos
reales antagonistas con motivaciones
suficientes como para que representen
una amenaza real afortunadamente
el antagonista actual del manga parece
que será un personaje que verdaderamente
valga la pena
y yo sé y entiendo perfectamente que
goku sea el protagonista el personaje
principal de la serie pero existen otros
personajes entra como receta que también
merecen reconocimiento no todo tiene que
ser goku salvando a los demás el arco
del torneo universal corrigió muchísimos
de los errores existentes en super eso
muchas cosas bien
una de ellas fue darle el protagonismo a
otros personajes
rossi tuvo su momento vegueta tuvo su
momento johan y piccolo también [ __ ]
hasta la androide 17 que no lo veíamos
desde hace años pues la emb y pide al
torneo y quiero más de eso momentos en
los que cada personaje cada guerrero
pueda tener su momento de protagonismo
momentos en los que pueden demostrar que
son más que personajes que están ahí
para acompañar a goku y vegeta sí es
bueno tener algo que está repartiendo
madera 2 a todo el mundo pero en
ocasiones sería genial que se acordarán
de otros personajes y los dejen brillar
un momento
kiril el caldito que se anda muriendo
cada dos capítulos enfrentados al poder
de un dios y esto hace que es algo que
la serie necesita arreglar niveles de
poder
cómo es posible juego q si no tan fuerte
como un dios teniendo el poder para
destruir galaxias yo que sé tal vez un
maldito universo y que tenga que
convertirse en súper sunday in blue y
ponerse serio contra cojan androide 17 o
creel y a estas alturas gocco con un
puñetazo le rompe a creer en toda su
calva cabeza he visto que los fans les
gusta sacar excusas como que los
personajes han estado entrenando muy
actualmente o qué hago con sus peleas
estaba conteniendo la vida si todos
ellos son personajes muy fuertes sí pero
con el nivel actual que poseen y cocu
que probablemente ya arriba alice o
supere al del dios de la destrucción que
más estúpido el hecho de que ahora para
enfrentarse a cualquier enemigo o así
sea una pelea amistosa tenga que ir
directo a su transformación más poderosa
parece que no sería algunos personajes
se vuelven mucho más fuertes o no porque
es conveniente para el guión y creo que
más que la escala de poder se dé una
mala escritura en la serie o simplemente
a guionistas perezosos milenio ártico
problema con qué krilin tenga el poder
para pelear uno a uno con coco en su
estado de dios
si quieres hacer al pelón alguien con el
nivel de una deidad de [ __ ] madre pero
dame una explicación razonable de cómo
consiguió esos poderes al menos que me
en una razón del por qué los personajes
se ven tan fuertes de la nada pero si me
dices que se olvidó fuerte porque así
porque el yo lo necesitaba medio test
este tal vez de un tema que esté muy
relacionado con lo que dije personajes
con mejor desarrollo porque simplemente
las cosas necesitan estar mejor
argumentadas con una buena justificación
una razón de ser que no están los
niveles de poder como que bueno este
personaje es igual de fuerte que un dios
porque si si van a ser los personajes
más fuertes o directamente a crear
personajes fuertes deben dar una
explicación detrás de toda esa fuerza ya
que dragon ball es un son en una serie
enfocada en las batallas pues las peleas
los personajes y su fuerza deben tener
mucho más balance y sentido
en la batalla de los dioses se nos
representaban la nueva forma el nuevo
estado que alcanzaría a goku en su
personal indios todos estábamos
sorprendidos y queríamos saber más de
esta transformación pero después
super sostenible y después su parte de
jim ross y la evolución del súper céret
in blue train tinto butter instinto
perfecto
siempre es bueno ver a protagonista de
una serie entrenar y conseguir un nuevo
poder presentar algún bolso poder esto
es excesivo en poco más de 130 episodios
nos han mostrado ya 6 transformaciones
obviamente cada una más fuerte que la
anterior pero no es un hecho de que
hayan 300.000 transformaciones sino que
no le dan el tiempo para mostrarlas en
su totalidad me explico tendrá como
receta la primera transformación que
tuvimos fue el súper sellering que nos
explicó que era cómo afectaba al poder
de su usuario e incluso antes de los
juegos de shell o cúbico and entrenaron
enteramente en estado súper sade jim
para controlar absolutamente el poder de
esta transformación está seguirnos
explicarón bastantes cosas por supuesto
al gym pero ahora en súper con su
personalidad y en dios por ejemplo que
son la transformación mucho más compleja
tanto por la manera de conseguirla como
por el hecho de que literalmente
convierten su usuario en un dios no se
nos explica un [ __ ] de este estado se
nos dice que si hace poco más fuerte y
lo convierte en un dios y ya a pelear y
en menos de 15 capítulos ya nos dan otra
transformación además de que en cuanto
sale una nueva transformación la
anterior queda en el olvido en cuanto se
los mostró el superyó de jim blue o que
comenzó a hacer esta transformación en
el 90% de sus batallas bien donando el
hecho de que tiene otras cuatro que les
pueden
también ahora sólo vemos en este estado
muy rara vez usando las demás la serie
debe entender que no queremos una
transformación nueva incentivo cada
capítulo sino que sería bueno que
leyeran cierto espacio y reconocimiento
a todas las demás formas que tienen q
porque con este paso que la serie lleva
capaces que con este nuevo estado
nuestra instinto ocu ahora lo usar en
todo momento ignorando sus demás
formaciones estando en la gracia estos
poderes deberían ser usados cuando de
verdad sea necesario y utilizando
ciertas transformaciones dependiendo del
enemigo con el que se vayan a enfrentar
en vez de transformaciones vacías deben
enfocarse en lo que hizo el manga que
fue a darle un buen enfoque argumento a
cada aumento de poder o darle técnicas
icónicas de cada fase como el sello de
restricción divina del súper jabalí en
dios o al puño del dragón del súper soy
de ying 3
dragonball super pk de dos cosas su
absurdo y excesivo humor y su completa
falta de sangre contenido explícito
tal vez sea causa de su horario de
emisión en japon que es un horario
infantil o que simplemente quieren
llegar a un público más amplio pero es
demasiado notorio el hecho de que la
serie está mucho más enfocada a un
público menor comenzando por su humor sí
es verdad que dragon ball y dragon ball
z tienen muchos momentos cómicos y la
sre es tratada con bastante humor pero
era un humor que tanto público infantil
como adolescente o adulto podrían
disfrutar incluso algunas veces
dirigidos más a los adultos con chistes
sutiles pero algo más de adultos la
serie sabía crear situaciones graciosas
sin caer en lo ridículo cosa que a super
le encanta hacer muchos personajes en
súper adoran hacia el ridículo y esto
hace que la serie se note con un tono
gracioso pero no ese que te hace reír
sino de ese que te da pena ajena este
tono infantil también se notaba por la
falta de sangre en la serie algo que
hacía ética en las batallas de dragon
ball z el hecho de que se sentían más
reales dentro de lo que cabe se sentía
la fuerza en cada golpe si alguien lo
hacía [ __ ] pues lógicamente sangraba
es más la mayoría de las peleas
terminadas con ambos oponentes sangrando
y agotados pero peleando con sus últimos
la sangre le da algo de humanidad de los
personajes para saber que pueden ser
heridos que les duele cada golpe y que
tienen un límite en esos pequeños
detalles hacían que las batallas fueron
emocionantes al sentirse algo de riesgo
en cada golpe pero en su poder lo único
que deben hacer es escupir un montón de
saliva cuando les dan un golpe fuerte en
el estómago jaja pero único que se le
pone de sangre es a picor o porque no
lagartija y la sangre verde no se
censura verdad en dragon ball super hay
personajes con niveles de un dios que
ahora puede destruir planetas con la
mirada y aunque estos personajes se
rompan lamadrid por horas y horas con su
poder al máximo lanzando sin golpe tras
golpe cada uno más fuerte que el
anterior en ocasiones con intenciones de
matar incluso lo único que pasa es que
se rompe la parte superior de su ropa y
terminar con muchos rasguños más allá de
eso nada en dragon ball goku derrotado a
sus enemigos atravesando los en cambio
algo q es súper recibe ataques que
pueden destruir planetas enteros pero
sólo resulta con un par de arañazos la
falta de sangre hace que las peleas se
sientan falsas y menos emocionantes
porque no importa cuántas veces golpees
a goku cuantas veces lances energía o
incluso cuántas veces lo atraviesas
nunca vas a sangrar quitándole mucha de
la humanidad el personaje pareciendo que
parezca de hule
super necesita en pocas palabras tener
las agallas necesarias para agregar
contenido más maduro y explícito a la
serie
[Música]
estas son algunas cosas que en mi
opinión pueden ayudar a que dragon ball
super sea mucho mejor como serie con
esto en nuevamente no quiero decir que
no me gusta era como el super k la serie
sea mala o que la odia me considero muy
muy fan de todo dragon ball de hecho es
mi serie favorita simplemente me encanta
desde niño que la veo y le tengo mucho
cariño a dragon ball y super no es la
sección tiene bastantes fallos sí pero
eso no quiere decir que sea mala una de
las cosas que hizo tan grande dragon
ball es su sencillez dragon ball nunca
necesitó un argumento super elaborado
para ser genial y ahora así con toda esa
sencillez la grama autoridad le tenemos
mucho cariño a la serie por sus peleas
sus personajes tan carismáticos y su
didáctica historia me gusta la con ball
super pueden mejorar obviamente pero aún
así me encanta la serie y se queda
seguir viendo y le seguiré pasando
genial con su historia y con lo que sea
que le depara el futuro a dragon ball
quiero también aclarar que esta lista
está basada enteramente en mi opinión
según ustedes no está de acuerdo con
alguna de las cosas mencionadas en este
vídeo pues vayan sea la mía es broma ya
que no está de acuerdo conmigo ya está
bien cada quien tiene su propia opinión
y sus propios gustos así que si creen
que se me escapó alguna otra cosa que
iba a estar en este
no duden en dejármelo en los comentarios
me gustaría leer sus opiniones hasta la
próxima
[Música]